you're watching swype coming up on the
show Angela finds out how drilling into
ice is helping scientists in France
monitor climate change I meet one of the
British entrepreneurs trying to bring
Polaroid into the digital age and is the
xbox one s a worthy overhaul to the Xbox
one find out in our gained review with
Chris hello and welcome to swipe from
sky central in London I've been in the
capital this week dimitar silicon
valley-based british entrepreneur but
first we go to France where angela has
been looking at how technology is
helping scientists monitor global
warming from one of the most iconic
glassy is there and the rate of change
is really alarming researchers the
glaciers in the Alps hold the key to
understanding how the climate has
changed over millions of years and how
it will change in the years to come but
they're disappearing this is all too
evident at the murder glass also known
as the sea of ice it's losing between
four and five meters in thickness on
average per year suggesting the glacier
which is over 4 miles long is suffering
the effects of climate change last year
the in 2015 Aldo glacier in France melt
a lot because we have not many snow in
winter and the summer is very hot and
the glacier lost a lot of
lot of mass there are various systems
being used on the glaciers in the region
to help the scientists complete
calculations on their movements Lucinda
Sanjay we have a long data set from the
surface under the glacier with my
instrument we put sis ma meter 22 to
record the the fracture the movement of
the water movement of the glacier and we
also satellite photos of course and we
put GPS and the on the on the surface
and we drill we must drill next year
many holes with with hot water to
measure also the the pressure of the
water inside the glacier Luke took this
time lapse of the glacier sliding 2
meters per day showing years of
compacted ice flowing down the mountain
the sheer volume of Isis just
disappeared here is very apparent now
this was a top level of the glacier in
1820 but now it's 200 meters down there
an international team of glaciologists
will be collecting ice cores like this
from the area this month to preserve the
record of information stored within them
the team will then transport them to a
base in the Antarctic analyzing air
bubbles in the cause will tell
scientists what the climate was like at
different periods of the Earth's history
they say this will help give a better
insight into how it might change in the
future not simple it's not simple it's
not the glacier retreat because we have
time a chance at some of the vishal
retreat now a lot because we have less
and less ice arrive because the glacier
is very slow now although complex the
techniques being used to keep a nice
record for future generations to analyze
will be crucial a scientists here warned
that glaciers in the Alps lower than
3,500 meters in altitude will disappear
before the turn of the next century
Angela Barnes Sky News in xiamen II
France stay with us still so calm I'll
be meeting the startup trying to revive
one of the most famous names in
photography coming up right after a
round up of some of this week's tech
news a bar in hove has made a bold move
by fitting a mobile phone signal blocker
the owner of the gin tub says he wants
people to talk to each other he's
installed a copper Faraday cage in the
ceiling which he describes as a tin box
that prevents signals from coming in
instagram has launched a new feature
called stories similar to snapchat it
allows you to post photo and video
slideshows that disappear within 24
hours it's rolling out globally for iOS
and Android over the next few weeks
astronomers are warning an asteroid
could hit earth and caused immense
suffering and death in the next century
the asteroid known as Ben who is
predicted to pass between Earth and the
moon in 2135 NASA's launching an
unmanned spacecraft to get more
information about it and here's an
interesting ways a heads of the shops
this straddling bus in China took its
first test ride this week engineers
designed the transit elevated bus to
help solve the country's notorious
traffic problems stick around for our
games review we look at microsoft's new
console and the best games to play on it
according to chris do you remember the
classic polaroid cameras that magic of
being able to take a picture and then
see it print out in seconds it was all
the rage in the 80s these days though
it's retro nostalgia but one startup has
launched a photo sharing app featuring
the famous name and I went to meet its
co-founder to find out more huh dori
swing lets you capture one second
moments and then reach into the Polaroid
picture and make it move either by
touching it like this or by tilting your
fight and swinging it back and forward
so I'm gonna take a picture of you what
you need to do is to do some kind of
movement so Polaroids allows you to
capture movement so do your wave like
that and now I'm capturing a one-second
moment and it developing you're done and
then you get this amazing effect
so you can kind of reach into it and
you're almost moving you okay with that
but how is that anything to do with the
old classic Polaroid's so what we aim to
do was to recreate the magic that you
felt when you took a Polaroid picture on
one of these things and translate that
into a mobile phone so if it's okay with
you I want to take an old-school
Polaroid picture of you okay okay slow
wave again do the waving thing let's do
it exactly the same okay that's it note
to self though must come up with a more
exciting pose and again and again and
again three two one go Tommy's not the
only one talking up his company's new
app meet photographer Diana Gomez I just
wanted a professional photographer like
you with this fantastic studio what
would you want with a photograph a gap
like this to show movement on a steel
photograph has always been I guess one
of the greatest challenges for a
photographer you'd really use this and
your work yes of course you know i love
i love the fact that you could just
create a new set of images and just use
it for different things all the time
different things like teaching me how to
stand and of course taking a 3d selfie
but watching from the sidelines is
photography and tech expert Phil Hall
after I invited him along to give some
impartial feedback film come on in final
word swing would you reckon yeah it's
good fun but I'm just worried about it
in an overcrowded market there's lots of
photo apps out there that you know
instagrams dominating the market place
just I don't know how long it's gonna
last what it's about Tommy well Polaroid
is one of the most iconic brands in the
world at the moment it's a nap but we
want to see those photos those polaroid
pictures going all over the digital
world the physical wall eventually and
the virtual world I'm struggling to see
the connection with Polaroid and the app
so personally it just doesn't is quite
so disconnected from my point of view ok
that sense of magic when it appears
before your eyes and be able to really
reach in and physically touch it so
those feelings that you got with the old
Polaroid that's what we wanted to
recreate you're never gonna please every
customer are you told me the only way to
solve this is with a 3d selfie ok ok
ready well at least we all went home
smiling Gemma Morris Sky News now is the
xbox one s worth the upgrade here's
Chris the xbox one s is Microsoft's new
smaller version of the xbox one Xbox one
is a huge giant thing look if you
remember VHS players like that big but
they've made it way smaller and it also
supports 4k which is cool if you've got
a 4k TV this is the only game console
that supports 4k at the moment so you
want to watch an ultra-high definition
blu-ray you can do that if you want to
stream stuff in 4k you can do that and
it also has HDR which is high dynamic
range which sounds like something that
doesn't make any sense but it makes
everything just look nicer in 4k like
blacks are black or white so white stuff
like that it comes with the new
controller which is slightly redesigned
but the main thing I quite liked was the
fun sticks still a bit nicer and it's
got the textured grip on the back which
came with the elite controller
originally you've got a USB port on the
front now the USB port is on side you
have xbox one you have to plug your
controller in you'd have to move
everything and put down the front now
that makes so much sense it's so much
better you're going to pick up an xbox
one s you haven't had one before for the
rising two as a game you need to get it
is absolutely brilliant game it's a
racing game but I've never been like a
huge racing game kind of guy like I
can't even drive so car games they don't
do too much for me generally but this
one is insanely fun you take part in the
horizon festival it's like a music
festival mixed of a massive car meet up
where they all do races and stuff got
every sort of car every sort of terrain
golf road it looks stunning even if you
don't normally play driving games the
concrete unlike you do cool stuff like
there's special challenges where you
have to do stuff like race up fighter
jet we won't do that at a car it's
really fun
so the next name I'd recommend if you've
just picked up the xbox one s would be
Ori and the blind forest which is a game
you can download once you've got the
console will set up so this is a sort of
puzzle action platforming thing that is
absolutely stunning like this game plays
wonderfully and it looks beautiful and
it's also got a really cool story like
it were it reminds me of like a Pixar
film in terms of the sort of emotional
depth that the story gets from something
seemingly so simplistic you play the
tiny little guardian spirit you ran
around you jump platform so puzzles all
that stuff like I said but this game it
will break your heart just do what I'm
not a spoil anything but it will
complete it destroyed me like I played
it I was just at the beginning but it
gives you back your heart piece by piece
as you go along and yeah it's beautiful
there's a definitive edition you can get
now which you can download that's like
it's not how much money and it's got
everything in the game that they
released as extra content later down the
line so definitely check that out if
you've just got your new xbox
well that's it for this week take a good
look at Sky News on mobile tablet couch
ops got a cute and snapchat for the
latest tech stories throughout the week
and we'll see you again next time
bye-bye